[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm Dana Badawi welcome to the
Emmanuel centre in London for this
intelligence squared debate this weekend
Donald Trump marked his 100th day in
office as president of the United States
and what hm uh Lewis period it's being
we've seen his travel ban on seven
muslim-majority countries thwarted
relations with Russia have soured and
his critics have said this has
vindicated their fears but Trump's
supporters say no not at all he's made a
tremendous impact by reasserting u.s.
leadership for instance he dropped the
mother of all bombs on militants in
Afghanistan and he's fired
cruise missiles on Syrian military bases
so how is the 46 President of the United
States doing well that is our motion
today Trump is making America great
again and we have an excellent panel for
you arguing for the motion Conrad blacks
the canadian-born financier historian
and former owner of The Telegraph
newspapers and Aaron banks a big batter
of brexit in the UK he was one of the
first British politicians to visit
president-elect Trump and arguing
against the motion
Kizer Khan the Muslim American lawyer
and father of the US Army captain who
was killed in action in Iraq and an
apple farm the Pulitzer prize-winning
historian and quorum missed on The
Washington Post that is our panel
welcome to you all
[Applause]
[Music]
so shortly you will hear from the
panelists - for the motion - against I'm
then going to throw open the debate to
the floor now you in the audience you
know you are asked to vote as you are
coming into the hall before the debate
because we want to know what your
thinking is before you hear what our
speakers has to say and then we're going
to ask you to vote again when you heard
the arguments for and against the motion
to see if any views have been swamped so
let's have the opening statements from
the panelists and speaking first for the
motions Trump is making America great
again
Conrad Falacci former chairman of the
Telegraph newspapers and numerous other
publications his written biographies of
presidents ste Roosevelt and Richard
Nixon as well as a strategic history of
the United States Conrad Black please
make your way to the lectern thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Santa I will start with facts
which I believe are germane to the
question as its formulated and just
sites and statistics I know that
statistics can always be made to prove
anything but in this case I give you my
word that they are objectively selected
and are not misleading in the first 16
years of this new century the GDP per
capita of the United States has grown by
one percent and if it had grown in this
period at the rate that it did in the
last 20 years of the 20th century the
people the families of individuals of
the United States would be on average
twenty percent wealthier than they are
in this period 15 million people fallen
out of the workforce the percentage of
Americans above the age of 20 who work
has declined by nearly 5 whole percent
and the number of hours work any kind of
legitimate work in the United States in
that period has declined by the shocking
total of 12 percent these these are very
dangerous figures in a very dangerous
trend and the impact of this is is a
very burdensome to the country and it's
very worrisome to the country and you
must remember that the ethos of the
United States is one of such optimism
and such ambition but it is not a
country accustomed the concept of
decline at any time and it has never had
a period of absolute or comparative
decline such as it has had in the last
15 to 20 years and it very much concerns
the whole country but coming up to the
election it must be said this was not
mentioned by the established elements of
either party it was very little
mentioned in the media and and it was
really only seized upon by outlier
candidates to some degree senator
Sanders who is a democratic quasi
Marxist and on the other side of the
Republican right the senator Cruz now if
you people are startled by Donald Trump
you will really be shocked if you've got
a good look at senator Cruz he's pitched
his whole campaign to the corn covers
and the wool hats and the people with
automatic weapons and the rear windows
of their pickup trucks and and he as far
as I can see would hand over the
Pentagon to the National Rifle
Association and he declared in
Indianapolis last spring that God told
him to run for president and in this
last election year in policy terms Trump
was a moderate he was he is in favor of
universal health care it's obviously
going to be with some difficulty that he
gets there but he's in favor of it at
least as a concept and he is in favor of
lower taxes for lower income people and
higher taxes for higher wealth people
and in policy Turner's he's a very
reasonable person the the fact this is
Clinton referred to a half of Trump
supporters as deplorable was extremely
unwise given that she was after all
running for the highest office in the
country then these people are worried
and what occurred was an assault by
Trump upon the entire political
establishment he ran against all
factions of both parties he ran against
practically all the media almost all of
audible and visible academia here Anna
gates the lobbyists the polling
organizations the bureaucracy Wall
Street and quite explicitly that
infestation of useful to his enemies
idiots in Hollywood Iran against Allah
and he won and he has won with a program
that is quite radical he has a tax plan
which I understand he tends to reveal at
the end of this week which will include
taxes sharply reduced for all
corporations sharply reduced for lower
income great
a tax incentives to start have decades
late renovation of national
infrastructure incentivizing two
trillion dollars of retained profit
overseas to return to the US and he has
already dismantled with nonsense of
global warming and he has he has already
shown that he will give the country as
has been mentioned a foreign policy that
is neither of a trigger-happy
belligerency of george w were the penn
glossy and fantasy of obama telling
America's enemies and allies to change
roles in places
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed Conrad Black
now the first voice against the motion
kiesza Khan is a muslim-american lawyer
whose son was killed in action in Iraq
at the 2016 US Democratic Party
convention he denounced Trump's call for
a ban on migrants from some Muslim
countries and questions his
understanding of the US Constitution
Keitha Khan please make your way to the
election
good evening America is discovering the
true nature of this president and the
motion is Trump is making America great
again and I stand before you against the
motion here are the facts you remember
the very loudly pronounced bigoted a
statement by candidate Trump was I will
build the wall and Mexico will pay for
the wall well friends we all know Mexico
is not paying for the wall and the wall
is not being built the reason is that to
build the wall you need funding and
Congress has loudly announced that they
will not allocate any funding for the
building of the wall so we are waiting
remember the second promised and loudest
promise was we will repeal and replace
Affordable Care Act in United States he
promised that during the election
campaign and then he tried and you saw
three weeks ago how it was defeated when
it went to the Congress his party is the
majority party in the Congress yet that
proposal was defeated third jobs I will
create thousands of jobs in United
States and where are the jobs we don't
see them even in the near future we
don't see them so that is the job
promised I'm a Muslim American I am a
patriotic Muslim American I consider
myself responsible for the safety and
security of the United States
we heard Muslim ban number one and
Muslim ban number two you all know where
the
and is rule of law has prevailed the
fifth and much-talked-about
accomplishment is the appointment of
Judge Gorsuch to Supreme Court he is
going to make America great again
no he's not Senate rule were changed
instead of sixty votes were changed the
simple majority that is the only
accomplishment that you know that he had
been able to do remember within hundred
days within hundred days his National
Security Advisor agent of foreign
governments was disgraceful he walked
out of White House was asked to resign
keep these issues that I mentioned to
you is this the way to go earn one of
the most enviable democracy in the world
I oppose this motion
you heard my brief statements and my
story that continues my journey that
continues is in opposition of Donald
Trump in support of democracy democratic
values safety and security of my country
safety and security of Europe safety and
security of mankind thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Kabir Khan now our second
speaker for the motion is Aaron banks
you perform a major donor - you kicked
the UK Independence Party in co-founder
of leave dot EU you recently quit you
kicked to set up a new populist
political force called the patriotic
Alliance whose aim is to bring Trump
style politics to the UK
he's also launched the
anti-establishment news website West
Monster which is modeled on the American
websites Breitbart
and The Drudge Report Aaron please make
a rate of election thank you good
evening I just wanted to tackle the last
point of last week you made as a
businessman to achieve anything in a
hundred days is pretty much impossible
let alone make America great so I think
Donald Trump has set out to actually do
the things he said he was going to be
elected to do
the fact that the establishment both in
the Republican Party and elsewhere tried
to stop him is not an indictment of his
presidency after 100 days what I wanted
to do is reel back the clock a little
bit look about the reason Donald Trump
was elected in the first place
globalization has caused massive
dislocations within the world we've seen
huge amounts of money transfer from the
poor to the rich in fact just today I
left Mayfair in the morning we went down
to platinum visited what is the poorest
part of England and place called a wig
this overlooked it is a shambolic place
the contrast between Mayfair another
area that was utterly just followed out
to be frank it takes us where we joined
the Trump story in Mississippi where we
were asked to go down or larger was
asked to go done speaking Jackson
Mississippi and 20,000 people came out
to listen to Donald Trump and listens of
Raj there were another 20,000 queued
down the road and the reason was that in
essence the
they were disappointed at the political
class and the fact I think Conrad
mentioned or the economics that's the
only one you need to know is a salary of
a normal American of flat line for over
eight years it you know the communities
were closed out
and so Donald Trump as a response a kind
of almost anti political response now I
would agree with some of the comments
the previous speaker he's a deeply
flawed candidate a deeply flawed
president but what he represents as a
catalyst and I don't think that Donald
Trump will make America great again I
think the people of America will when we
look at the major policies which you
know is to bring bank jobs into America
to look at how you could change the tax
system to actually bring companies back
in there's something like two trillion
dollars parked offshore out of America
because the tax system of America means
that corporation tax there is 38% the
highest in the Western world and I think
he's got a whole range of policies that
will be very beneficial but I think we
have to see it in the context and same
as breaks it why the breaks that happen
people in London didn't see a come in
because they didn't go out and look if
you actually look at what's happened to
communities in our country
they've been hollowed out and actually
was a reaction from the poorest in our
society that thought that the
politicians and the the sort of
corporations it just wasn't in their
benefit and I think that's very much
where Donald Trump has come in I think
you know I watched the French election
macrons going to win I can tell you if
the entire British establishment line up
and say pick that guy and not marine
lepen in the same way that everybody
lined up against Trump
there's going to be big trouble and
don't rule it out so I think from my
perspective it's not a question whether
Donald Trump will make America great
again
it's whether he will free out Americans
to once again make America great again
that's my that's my key point I had to
make thank you
[Music]
thank you very much indeed Aaron banks
now speaking secondly against the motion
Trump is making America great again is
an apple balm American journalist and
Pulitzer prize-winning historian she's a
regular columnist on the Washington Post
and is also a visiting professor at the
London School of Economics where she
runs a program on disinformation and
21st century propaganda and please make
your way to the lectern thank you
[Music]
thank you I have to start by saying I'm
terribly sorry
no mr. black no mr. banks Trump is not
making America great again
you've been conned we are it was amusing
to hear Conrad blacks speak about facts
this is not a president who respects
facts we already know by now that he's
lied to his supporters he's lied to the
people in the heartland who voted for
him he has not kept any of the
legislative promises that he made for
his first hundred days and yes he did
make them there on a piece of paper you
can find them he may never keep them we
know that his populism was a total farce
his allegiance is not to the people who
elected him you know or his allegiance
is to the billionaires and to the
lobbyists and to Wall Street and to the
people who filled his cabinet and who
run much of his White House and above
all his allegiance is to himself we know
that he spent more time golfing in his
first hundred days in the previous four
occupants of the White House put
together we know he spends even more
time watching cable television because
since he doesn't have the attention span
to read or listen to briefings he tweets
and makes policy in response to whatever
he sees we also know that he will do
profound damage to American democracy as
you've heard already for mr. Khan but
Trump has already done really profound
damage to America's reputation around
the world as an ally as a trading
partner even as a serious country and
this is going to get worse and it's
going to get much worse every day the
incoherence deepens he's never going to
intervene in Syria he says but then he
saw or perhaps Ivanka saw pictures of
dead children on television and he
changed his mind he's going to get
Mexico to pay for a wall but actually it
will cost 12 to 15 billion dollars of US
taxpayers money he has a secret plan to
defeat Isis but actually his strategy is
no different from Obama's he's going to
challenge China on trade on Taiwan
but now he isn't he's going to make
friends with Russia but after the press
exposed his campaigns deep connections
to Russia he's decided for the moment at
least to drop that idea he's unable to
name the leader of North Korea with whom
he would like to tussle against whom he
appears to want to go to war he claimed
to dissent an aircraft towards the
Korean Peninsula but actually was
heading in the opposite direction he had
dinner with the Chinese dictator and
then offended South Korea who our allies
were defending by declaring incorrectly
that Korea actually used to be part of
China
he lies repeatedly about crowd sizes
about wiretapping about his campaign
team's relationship with Russian
officials about the crime rate about
employment figures about the trade
deficit he's lied about what he said he
would do he's lied to his supporters he
insults our allies not only South Korea
but Mexico Australia Germany Sweden
while fawning over dictators like Sisi
and erawan especially the owns property
in their countries teams of people the
defense secretary of the United States
the vice president have to be sent
around the world to apologise for the
foolish statements that Trump has made
but everybody knows it doesn't really
help every day he is teaching our allies
and they are learning that we will not
stand up for them that the American
president's word cannot be trusted since
taking office Trump has never displayed
the remotest concern for American
national interests or for American
values or indeed for most Americans but
he is obsessively interested in his own
business he's refused to separate
himself from his companies which are
nominally run by his sons or from the
multiple conflicts of interest that they
represent all over the world where does
this leave us America used to fight
kleptocracy this was actually a policy
of the US government but now America is
becoming a kleptocracy you know American
governments used to encourage others to
be more transparent this was part of our
foreign policy was to encourage our
partners and and our allies around the
world to increase transparency
our crew used to stand for democracy but
now America stands for nepotism as a
nation our ability to influence others
and shape the world has long derived not
just from military and economic power
but from the power of our ideas and from
the solidity of our system all of us
gone so no America is not being made
great America is being made corrupt and
inconsequential and tawdry and laughable
by Donald Trump who is the most
dishonest most venal and most malevolent
president that we've had in living
memory thank you
[Applause]
we've heard on our speakers and before
we go to the audience let me tell you
you're thinking before the start of this
intelligence squared debate our motion
Trump is making America great again for
the motion 13% one three percent against
the motion 67% and they don't know 20
percent so you've got a lot of
persuading to do gentlemen let's see
what happens when the members of the
audience are polled again after they've
listened to what you all have to say to
see if you've managed to influence the
people here so we've seen how you voted
before the debate let's now go through
the audience we then have any comments
or questions to our panelists and can I
see hands please we'll start with the
lady there thank you very much indeed
well I'm one of the undecided and and if
anything was prepared to want to active
agree with the motion but I am undecided
because mr. Trump has hasn't done half
the things that I wanted him to do but
the best thing that he ever did to say
when he became president was he was not
going to allow America to judge other
nations that he wanted to create a
nation in America that was so
inspirational that people would want to
copy him that he wouldn't be telling
their American becoming everybody else
had to behave okay thank you
yes so my question was just for the
gentleman supporting the merchant is
what is it that he's doing to make
America great so how is Trump putting
the great back into the United States of
America of course it was a great nation
and it just never ceased to be a great
nation at least since the end of the
u.s. Civil War so we're really talking
about reversing that
which I tried to describe in economic
terms though it occurs in other ways
it's like now the first time in American
history that the life expectancy of an
American has declined it's not chronic
as in Russia and Ukraine is declined by
one month if I well I'm added if I may
without filibustering the Mexican wall
will be built it will be built akiza
he's called for bids on it and I think
historians of the future will be
absolutely incredulous that the United
States tolerated 12 to 15 million
completely illegally unskilled people to
enter the country it would be like
between two and three million people
suddenly arriving here not speaking a
language and not having any skills to
make a living I mean he wants
immigration 11 but he wants it to be
legal he appointed English and by the
way in Mexico will pay for it because he
is going to alter the trade agreement
America has immigration laws America
does not have immigration policies
instead of building wall America should
develop immigration policies the wall is
a silly metaphor the wall will not stop
anything the wall doesn't change policy
it's another one it's a classic Trump
way of doing politics read a create a
fake project get energy done around it
and actually it will achieve nothing
[Applause]
Thank You Casey more questions in the
stories you've got the microphone
another well said that the American
people have been conned by from I'd
suggest that the American people had
been conned by the left-wing journalists
they were Washington Post but New York
Times for example the result was they
were saying on your extra night that it
was 98 percent certain that Hillary was
going to get elected now that become job
for it's done now this is the left-wing
media which is not telling the liberal
intelligentsia here for example that the
Americans working-class America's poor
are fed up with globalization they're
fed up with advises identity politics
and what they're looking for from
left-wing journalists in some
understanding of what's going on why
people are so unhappy that they vote for
Trump so instead of justice any words
hatred of Trump why is there some
reflection going on about why left-wing
journalists got it's so wrong at the
base and at the New York Times
okay fine thank you remember 7850 and
[Music]
I used to work I used to work for Conrad
blacks spectator and then for his daily
telegraph so I didn't think I count as a
left-wing journalist center left center
right step yeah okay Oh center-right
publications at least that you worked
for thank you presuming that mr. Trump
has won where do you think his moral
compass point
okay thank you yep hold Donald Trump is
clearly against time in there and so he
said that you know our vaccine called
water damage is the truth and you don't
go against climate change the thing is
that where the vibrations the night -
the monsters the bone - how will you
deal with this
[Applause]
yes it's both sides
I was wondering since the beginning of
the trial administration would you say
the tension and hostility between the
two parties of the diet's worth or would
you argue that there's more bridge
builders in Congress even with like a
united government okay let's just take a
couple questions where is Donald Trump's
moral compass Conrad or Aaron I mean and
I don't think you know Donal you don't
know well I've known him for over 20
years as moral compass is that he's a
very loyal friend had a perfect record
as an equal opportunity and player he's
been in rough businesses he's not a
genteel businessman and he's the only
businessman who's ever been the
president but he is a man whose words
absolutely reliable we had a Miss
co-developer in Chicago he came in right
on budget right on time and when I had
my legal difficulties he volunteered to
come and testified for me and and he is
a loyal friend and not to be compared to
many of our other neighbors who have
miraculously recovered from this amnesia
but many of whom I got my telephone
number for 10 years he has his
limitations and he answers in Felicity's
like great on me as much as I'm sure
they do on you but he should not be
described in these of registers he has
achieved a completely unprecedented feat
in being the only person in the history
of the United States he never sought a
political office never had a military
command and took over from outside first
a political party and then the
government he did it because the people
knew that they had suffered from 15
years of chronic miss government and he
has a program to put it through and you
can't do it 908 Thank You Erin just
picking up
I just wanted to go back to something
Ana said earlier which was America's
going down the track in nepotism yet she
wanted to still Hillary Clinton after
Bill Clinton will be the most corrupt
people in the 19 states of america so I
think that what am I going filing so I
think not regard themselves as the most
corrupt people in the United States the
American public had a clear binary
choice they chose Donald Trump what does
it say about your party that they
discarded this wonderful party that was
right and all the issues and voted for
Donald Trump the final thing I wanted to
say because I didn't say very much of
the lectin was the left-wing journalism
in America and we've just seen a string
of knees that is just basically the
meaning of the fact that he's been
president for 100 days what the hell I
mean what are you going to do in 100
days he's tried to repeal Obamacare he's
bringing forward tax policies and he's
trying to be probably the only
politician in the history of the world
essentially trying to deliver his
promises I asked Ebonics we want to
respond to that but also to remember
some of the questions that we've been
given in the teachers and the little boy
about she knows I've been going tonight
he doesn't even know what he promised he
doesn't understand Obamacare he says
we're going to have great health care is
going to be great for everyone
everyone's going to have lots of it's
going to be really cheap you know and
then a few days later somebody maybe
gives him one of those papers with
bullet points on it and lots of pictures
and he says oh I didn't realize health
care who knew health care could be so
complicated
well examined it was a man who had no
concept of what it would take to reform
health care he doesn't have anything at
all this is a vapid utterly vapid and
president thank you let's go to the
floor please yes I had a question for
Conrad back with his hat honors Bryton
historian if you like thinking back of
the last 20th century I can think of two
other American presidents who in this
country had been ridiculed and
that by journalists and others Richard
Nixon who had to decide Henry Kissinger
and was American president to it and the
door to China President Reagan who had
Shultz by his side Secretary of State it
was responsible
partly for the end of the Berlin Wall
and the fall of communism I don't know
if Trump is making America great I asked
this he does appear to understand what a
red line is the former president didn't
thank you Thank You Chet Lexi I think
I've just aren't even elected at all and
just before Trump said he was going to
do a special deal with the UK trade deal
we were the top of the queue I hear now
that he's changes Michael and her Merkel
wouldn't do a deal with him is this yet
another example of in flip-flopping I
just thought Alan banks you might have a
view on that
okay thank you take it we'll take
another one like I grieve you that a
politician or president needs time to
make changes but given that easily
infuriating the judiciary infuriated the
media and possibly more importantly
infuriated the CIA do you think you'll
be in Nick's or Kennedy right Trump says
that the UK will be at the front of the
queue and then now it's the EU who ahead
in terms of the trade deal I mean the
article I read in The Sunday Times was
attributed to the unnamed source as
usual there was no actual tribute you
know that there was no source for that
story we know from our contacts of the
American administration they prioritize
a trade to a Britain so I don't I just
don't know where that stories come from
what I do know is the media's are wash
with misleading bad fake news I wouldn't
be surprised about isn't one of them
Conrad's like we had the question about
whether whether Trump was going to be a
Nixon or
or a Kennedy but also Nixon resigned
before he was impeached but I guess
that's what repeated asking CIA and the
leaders are against him if he can be a
Nixon or Kennedy not in the sense as you
may know by the way after all these
years there's not a scrap of evidence of
mr. Nixon broke any laws I mean people
did in the Republican National Committee
and in the White House just getting back
sure what about the question that you
know I better in that question I believe
was was they comment that he had
infuriated the media you don't
understand in this country that's war he
attacked the media because it was
misreporting everything in effect and he
was substantially right and he has got
around the media with the social media
and with his friends in the talk show
business rush limbaugh has five times as
many listeners everyday as the New York
Times has readers and it is worked but
let us remember that for 32 years from
1981 to 2013 one member or other bush or
Clinton families was President and Vice
President or Secretary of State if you
want nepotism bad news it he ran against
those families and the Obamas and they
were just passing the opposites back and
forth between me on to the questions and
then the one about to presidency with
his light in Europe Nixon and Reagan and
were they underestimated and at least
Tom understands a red line that was that
question to you particularly if it is is
it not true yeah I think I think that
most people now in even in this country
would acknowledge that Reagan in
particular and Nixon were capable
presence and and I think ultimately if
you people all come back in eight years
you'll still say the same about done
okay sorry the one last yes do say was
that Reagan's first hundred days was
very unpleasant
you know he had a whole deal of problems
and in fact probably just as tumultuous
as Trump so I think you can't judge a
presidency by the first hundred days
objectively all right he said you want
to come in at all
somebody had asked about model compass
yes
tramp has moral compass that is
self-promotion his model compasses
political expediency say whatever helps
you for the moment regardless of how it
will be changed when the circumstances
when the time change I have stood in
front of Trump waters I have answered
their questions where are the jobs we
were promised where is health care we
were promised we don't see this inside
we were promised things will change
immediately when I get into office you
will have jobs and thousands of jobs and
all that that is political expediency
misleading people and he did not win
that election the facts are what looking
into he won the election because of the
Electoral College he did not win the
popular votes never forget that thank
you for getting more questions in the
floor yay I have a question for the four
proponents of the components of the
motion I would like to know how you
would reconcile the idea of bringing
back jobs for the downtrodden working
class that mr. black mentioned for
making America the land of opportunity
again with the incredible wealth that is
concentrated in the White House and the
cabinet I included any more ladies in
the audience can I just see could've had
an awful loss charts yes as a young lady
sir this is mainly directed to the for
years an emotion when do you think
Maryville was ever drape of a great okay
thank you
another one yeah
seamless them total job is not an
illogical person which as we basically
pointed out rollin Greg and other
presents were not analytic or intuitive
and indeed well but my question is who's
gonna be driving the agenda going in the
next four years since it's not the
person that has a clear strategy I mean
we know that few groups I would like the
panel to tell to try to answer this
question thank you very much indeed let
me give to the fourth emotion side how
do you reconcile helping the downtrodden
with the fact that it's the wealthier
cabinet in the White House and also when
with America ever great I think tank in
the the wealthy cabinet I mean these are
some of America's greatest business
people in the White House which is I
think a phenomenal thing and I think the
plan is they're going to reduce
corporation tax are going to make very
friendly business friendly environment
for America but they won't bring back
jobs and I go look to create a growth
rate of three or four percent rather
than they me make one percent or less
that we've been experiencing so I think
that this idea that just because they
rich they're going to you know somehow
do things to their benefit if anything
they don't have a vested interest
they're already rich
thank you can they reconcile the two
look we were promised what was the term
used cleaning the swamp training
draining the swamp the swamp has gotten
worse look at the cabinet look at the
appointments we were told there will be
transparency has anybody seen his tax
records and there's a reason he doesn't
want to share the tax record because
that is where lies the foreign influence
influence of the foreign banks that is
where lies the reason that such a
collusion between Russia and
Donald Trump and his advisors he will
not show so forget about jobs forget
about this is going to be self-promotion
every step who's driving the agenda is a
fascinating question we don't really
know we know we know who his advisors in
theory are we know who he's supposed to
be listening to but it seems to change
from week to week he was listening to
Steve Ben and now apparently he's not he
listens quite a lot to his son-in-law
was I said has no experience in any of
these issues and no knowledge of them
because he trusts family members if
we're lucky and this is a very strange
statement if you think about it if we're
lucky he will listen to the many
generals that he's appointed to
important jobs because they have this
sense of what America is and what
America can be and what it should do
abroad and when should stand for General
Madison and in general McMaster at the
National Security Council but it is a
very very odd moment in American history
where we have something almost like and
I don't even know that it's negative we
have a kind of soft military takeover we
are now really reliant on our generals
to keep to keep making the daily
decisions that will keep you know that
will keep American foreign policy
ticking over
and if we're lucky that will happen okay
I'll just date two or three more
questions please can I see yep
carry on we haven't had the luxury to
know mr. Trump for 20 years like Conrad
Black has but we've had the opportunity
to hear him speak and read his tweets
gentlemen before mentioned red lines and
that Trump is someone that has red lines
I question whether it has red lines when
it comes to behavior and I would put
forward that the presidency has a
certain gravitas that under certain
professionalism and that's important
it's hard to quantify the impact of that
but I would I would dare ask what your
view is I personally think that he's
keeping that somewhat and I'd be
interested in hearing what you think of
that and the importance of of that
[Applause]
yes I think he's cheapen didn't normally
and leave behind what you did for the
for the previous several decades I mean
I I true I don't know
Trump personally as Conrad does and I I
don't make my judgments about
politicians on those grounds in any case
but his use of his use of insult his lie
his his his attacks on Twitter his his
bizarre itself contradictions which
happened for one day to the next
his unseemly use of his own properties
to entertain people his unseemly use of
the Secret Service to fund those
properties I mean all of that I think
has really brought down the prestige of
the presidency in a way that's going to
be very very hard to recover yes I think
we can resolve many of the differences
here in the room by saying if if it we
are right era denial that he will put
his program through there will be
economic growth and it will address a
great many of the problems of the
vulnerable people in the country if he
can get his program through his program
will work if he can't get it through
he'll be a failure so we just have to
wait and see and all the talking by him
or any of us isn't going to be a
substitute for whether he can actually
deliver in the successful present but
Donald is not as he appears but that's
how he appears and I agree Keith it does
dilute the gravity and distinction of
that very great office and I don't like
it either Keith is shaking his head that
I apologize which Trump are you talking
about the one that insulted women by
grabbing their private parts that crumb
shame on him then shame on him now that
is the Trump that this was nodes
[Applause]
all right thank you very much indeed
well we had the debate that before I
announce the final vote to see who's won
this debate let me remind you of how you
the audience voted before you heard our
speakers today
so the pre debate results for the motion
Trump is making America great again for
the motions 13% against
67% don't know 20% and the final results
of this intelligence squared is debate
for the motion 20 percent against
emotions 76 percent and they don't know
4% so congratulations to against the
motion you wanna you also enjoy the
greatest swingley
[Music]
thank you very much indeed to our panel
Conrad black arrows bankers and utter
balm and keep the card
thank you all very much thank you thank
you to our audience and to all our
viewers wherever you've been watching
this and of course to intelligence we're
making it possible for me paying up is
always good bite
[Applause]
[Music]